I'm going all-in on this gamble of a DNews
episode, how is it that casinos keep people
gambling, even if they don't really want to?
Hey penny-slotters Trace here for DNews today
diving into the flashy world of gambling.
Literally, it's flashy, there are lights and
sounds and smells, adventures to be had money
to be won!
But when you're in a casino, hundreds of papers
and experiments are brought to bear to keep
you in their gilded halls.
So how do casinos keep us gambling?
increased arousal
A 2010 study in the Journal of Mental Health
Addiction found both lights and music created
"increased arousal" effects.
And a new study in the Journal of Neuroscience
looked at the brains of rats finding increased
arousal increases dopamine reception -- one
of our brain's powerful reward chemicals.
Feeling good means we spend more, so casinos
cash in on dopamine at every turn.
Numerous studies say more arousal means more
gambling, and faster music paired with flashing
lights makes people bet more quickly and spend
more money!
But that's not all…
colored lights
Marketers know the color red makes people
more aroused too.
And studies show red light makes people more
gambley than blue light!
Thus, casinos put red everywhere!
The Journal of Gambling Studies revealed a
bunch of other insights into gambling behavior
as well.
Things like "the illusion of control," the
idea that if you're pushing a button or pulling
a lever, you have control over the situation…
and if the risk seems low and you get an immediate
response to your bet, you'll bet more, and
then more.
free drinks/design
Some casinos even offer free drinks, great,
right?
For the casino.
Alcohol lowers your inhibitions and increases
expectations, further increasing play.
architecture
Even the architecture has evolved.
I find this particularly fascinating.
Originally casinos focused on "gaming design:"
all the slot machines and tables were lined
up, all together in a maze-like configuration.
It was thought that this design would make
us step up and gamble at every turn.
But based on scientific studies, casino design
has been radically redefined.
New casinos are based on the idea of "adult
playgrounds" with high-ceilings and expansive,
opulent, easy-to-navigate spaces; the Bellagio
is the quintessential example.
Old-style casinos famously avoid windows and
clocks to help gamblers lose their sense of
place and time, but "playground" casinos make
people feel happy and comfortable, with sunshine,
high-ceilings and art; keeping us gambling,
having fun, and spending that money.
A study published in the journal Environment
& Behavior proved that this is working.
People like the playground design, especially
women.
In the compact "gaming design" women felt
crowded by others around them, if they were
too close to other people they'd gamble less.
The adult playground design mitigates these
problems, and women now gamble even more.
Slots, for example, are historically very
popular with women, and revenue increased
over 30 percent since 1970.
It turns out, adding windows, bright colors,
and a resort feel, has a huge payoff for the
House.
The research showed, gamblers in a resort
playground casino feel more comfortable and
are reminded to have fun constantly.
So they do.
oxygen
The thing casino's don't do, though, is pump
in oxygen to give gamblers a modest high.
It's a myth, dating back decades.
What they actually do is pump in scents which
keep people aroused (back to that arousal
effect, thing) and according to the scent
designer for one company who does it, AromaSys:
refreshing and soothing scents keep people
gambling longer.
conclusion
In the end, casinos cash in on exploiting
our psychology to the tune of 240 billion
dollars a year.
They do it with the games, the decor, the
drinks, the smells, assaulting our senses
to get us to make it rain in the desert in
Vegas and elsewhere.
But what about gambling addiction?
Isn't that worth considering?
Gambling addiction does have a genetic component,
meaning if your mother or father has gambling
addiction, you could too!
Laci explains how that works here.
I don't really like gambling, I'm just not
taken in by it all…
I like wandering the hotels, but I don't feel
the need to pump quarters into a slot machine.
But how you y'all feel?
Do you gamble?
Have you stopped to think about why?